a horror movie about drunk teens at a
waterpark what could go wrong yes aqua /
falls a long line of horror movies that
take place at theme parks remember
Hellfest part of this guy is very much
alive remember final destination 3
remember piranha 3dd bring me my legs
we'll take those movies cut the budget
by 95% and you'll have aqua slash a
movie so bad it made me want to Aqua
slash myself these are horrible so come
along and join me on this magical
waterslide of death as we explore this
absolute batshit movie and don't forget
to Like and subscribe for more insane
movie breakdowns for those of you who
don't know aqua slash is all about the
graduating class of Valley Hills High
School celebrating their graduation at a
water park this is already a nightmare
for me as I grew up a fat kid and me and
water parks don't exactly have a good
history they like - but the night before
the kids are about to arrive - wet
Valley water park employees decide to
get it on near one of the slides and
saying this baby for you was that but
they're stocked by our film's antagonist
and machete-wielding bad guy who we
never see wait was that the Wilhelm
scream yep the next day that kids
arrived because it's gonna be a weekend
to die for seriously that's that's an
actual line they use in the film in fact
these slasher puns in this movie are so
common it becomes excruciating just
making sure you're dying to see me so I
guess you could say the main character
of this movie is Josh one of the
graduating teens whose band the blades
are playing at the party they have to
get in touch with the resident creepy
janitor lifeguard guy Carter who was
actually my favorite character in the
movie murder come on kid accidents
happen
yes way back in 88 there was a series of
murders at the park which were deemed
accidents but we'll get into that in a
bit so the student council decides to
run a charity car wash and it's just
friggin ridiculous
[Music]
I can't stress how vital this scene is
to the movie meanwhile the other
students party it up going down the
waterslide with bottles of booze
resulting in our first accident now the
pool area at the bottom of the slide is
covered in blood and shards of glass but
they just decide to reopen it without
draining it oh you think we should drain
the pool no no now do not drain the pool
dude I was there we also learned that
apparently accidents are common and
happen every year here including
multiple deaths how this place is still
open is beyond me we meet this guy
Michael Randolph don't hover thank you
go away he's a piece of work who happens
to be Josh's dad and a bigwig
millionaire looking to take over the
park
he also seduces the park owner's wife
Priscilla later that night Michael goes
to see his son play at the beach only to
see him get beat up by the resident
badass Tommy who has just found out josh
has been hooking up with his girlfriend
so this movie is at least trying to set
up multiple people as the possible
killer place your bets now will it be
Josh the lead singer of the blades who
was just embarrassed and beat up in
front of the entire school Tommy who was
just cheated on and is looking for
revenge Michael who's looking to take
over the park or Priscilla the owner's
wife who just found out the owner is
banging one of the students stay tuned
about 30 minutes into the movie is when
things start to actually get moving when
the mystery killer puts a bunch of
blades into one of the slides setting
things up for the film's bloody climax
now for those of you who bet Michael as
the killer well in the next scene he
gets shot in broad daylight but what I
love about this are the people going up
the slide in the background when he's
murdered it's it's almost as if they
didn't close the park for filming that
day and had to shoot the scene with
actual guests in the park like you'd
think if someone got shot in broad
daylight one of these kids would have
been like hey is something going on down
there Michael ends up surviving the
first shot and uncovers the bodies of
those two teens from the beginning as he
struggles to get away but he's killed
off-screen I mean come on you're in a
mechanical pump room like have his hands
get caught in a machine or something
like give me some sweet gory innovative
kills I'm not
here for this story and that's one of my
main criticisms of the film aside from
the waterslide climax the movie has no
cool kills which is really what we're
all here for right you're at a water
park with the potential for so many cool
unique ways to kill people like what the
hell are these things like have them
rain blood or someone can turn the
pressure on the water jets slicing up
through someone's butt hole I just came
up with these off the top of my head all
right you guys you're in for a treat
with one of my favorite scenes there's a
random kid named Jimmy at the beach who
somehow has a bleeding foot but it's
never explained why I can only assume he
cut it from the broken glass near the
slide then he complains to his mom I
paid for a full day we're getting that
full day and she just gives him a
plastic bag to put around it then he
finds a Walkman in the sand for no
reason and gets up limping away buddy
like look he looks happy and who can
forget Priscilla walking down the beach
with a dead bird she doesn't have any
gloves on or anything and no one seems
to notice this so the film is heading
towards its climax where they grads will
start off their day with races down the
water slides however one of the slides
has been set up with those giant ass
blades but before we begin we have to
start off with a really bad dance-off
for some reason
now it's the time we've all been waiting
for no not this guy in a speedo the race
of death but not if Tommy can help it
he's found that someone has tampered
with the slide and goes to stop it
don't go down but no one cares I don't
know about you guys but if I were at the
top of a waterslide and an employee came
up saying don't go down it it could
collapse there is no way I'm getting on
that slide but poor Tommy tries to stop
them and this happens as you can imagine
things don't go well for those who go
down the slide I mean it's pretty cool
totally fake like you can tell it's a
dummy but still kind of cool then chunks
of body part starts streaming out of the
slide like important is trying to stop
himself in going down and the old guy at
the bottom of the slide who's supposed
to radio in at the top when they can
send the next group of kids down well
this is what happens to him that's got
to hurt I don't care where you from so
what do you do when that happens keep
sending more kids down the slide now
remember that boy and his mom well
they're watching the massacre happen at
the bottom and just watch this did you
catch that the boy just disappears there
he is now he's gone there he is now he's
gone so Josh climbs up the stairs to
stop people from going down the slide
how the water isn't shut off where
people haven't heard the screams from
down below I don't know even the guy who
broke his ankle has enough time to climb
the entire tower before people realize
that [__] has gone haywire
both Josh and the old dude get thrown
down one of the slides but the movie
expects us to know this is one of the
slides that doesn't have the blades in
them somehow then there's this really
strange shot of two people just chilling
by the pool with dead body parts
floating around it like nothing's wrong
it's just really weird all in all nine
people are killed and the deaths are
pinned on Michael Randall as a
murder-suicide but it's only in our
final scene it's revealed who the real
killer is and the motives behind it Josh
finds out that he's inheriting all his
father's money and that his signature is
required for the waterpark deal to go
through
a deal whose money now goes to Priscilla
after her husband the owner was killed
in the massacre Oh her husband also
cheated on her we also get a flashback
to when she was a child and find out her
father was killed at the park when the
lifeguards were too busy making out to
save him why she'd work at the same
place her father died is beyond me so
this is kind of her way at getting back
at the teens murdering her cheating
husband and collecting a twenty million
dollar payday all in one as I said
earlier there are no real cool kills in
the movie aside from the slide it's
supposed to be a comedy but I don't
think I laughed once and the title
implies there's some kind of slasher on
the loose which really isn't the case
pass on aqua slash if you really want to
watch a water theme park or check out
piranhas three double D bring me my legs
that's all for today guys remember to
hit like and subscribe for more bat
takes follow me on twitter at think
story whitey and until next time
remember daddy loves you very much